welcome to this video playing in virar
virar ma'am is that right the third game
for today yeah this is like exclusively
produced for sunday September 20th after
I've screwed up yesterday it didn't
manage to do a pre uploading okay can I
do this it's a bit unusual water but I
think I can oh no you got 95 hi didn't
do that I don't mind that too much in
general this before idea is pretty
standard but the room what I was bad
okay yeah so yeah that's an interesting
interesting way of playing I think I can
go see 5 here it should be okay I need
to make sure that he's not blocking on
c5 some night to see five or so but this
looks a little bit better for wide I
believe maybe you for no doesn't do that
interesting think this one so that I
have a possible night c4 okay maybe
Rupert is sick so is this just pseudo
active and let's do it
and that's f form the thing that my
position has in its favors I'm a bit
better develop Jim got things quicker in
play you cannot take because of Bishop
g7 yeah here I can take c6 so what is
the point not sure you could be a
daughter I don't don't quite get it okay
yeah do I just take that on the seven or
night takes you five
I'm not sure it's two points but the
remaining pieces they are kind of kind
of bad okay I mean night b5 will cover a
pawn on d6 if you decide to take on d6
maybe it's ok
and night b5 yeah okay I can do that why
not just keep keep t6 yeah I was
thinking a four bit maybe just 93 or 94
is good as well okay now I no no no 94
it's got rooked is six let's be alert if
a four takes on each room and Knight c3
I can definitely play takes TX king is
six also not ideal
not sure what's the best way is
technically fortunately night year for a
94 it's not that bad actually now that I
think of it returning one pond let's do
that let's return one horn root is six
year I saw that and no III it looks
quite okay Brooke be too my name is
still root be true because he gets a
little bit too active him I didn't
really see that he can go to be true
that he gets to be true that was bad
check
not good check
and that plane
check so is there an alternative no I
guess not have to check and now is there
something that I can do to keep the Jeep
on probably not probably not okay so
some way to go to e5 that would be cool
night b5 time learning 96 for something
like that
check check check okay when always
attacking this this way huh didn't
didn't see that one coming check
weird or is he already playing on time
yard rookie to I was expecting but
anyway check check check 14 seconds
that's not exactly much
check check no it's they know very
clearly winning but of course the time
check check check yeah so I'm glad for
the leaderboard the draw check checking
I couldn't be 6 it wasn't this kid I had
to her head too whoa that was very close
who with absolutely no time yeah I was a
very house tricky the position on here
was nice but it was still come on let's
let's have a look there it was it was
practically still a bit tricky night
behave of course how stupid can you be
and he resides I was simply not seeing
it why not I cannot tell you yeah sure
that's very stupid actually took 20
seconds on that I really didn't think
about a move I was just only thinking
okay how can I we need five when not be
five is just this is forcing resignation
really I mean
he's losing and absolutely everything
Wow yeah this is not not that trivia
Roxy one is better i am probably and
therefore i wasn't sure i didn't really
see that he gets to be too so quickly I
thought I have a 3 root c1 or c2 but
black is far too active so that was
really bad play it was bad yeah yeah
sure yet just some way to him to draw
here for sure check check check check
check check check Android's rotation
it's certainly losing but yeah I'm very
tricky that was much influenced by me
whether spend time ok who want to finish
thanks for watching